[Music]
there are times I get so bashful being
nosed enough with Artem could we take
back I have been with my fiance John
five years now and I have not bumped and
grind another man like even out in the
cloud lake since then
weren't used to it seemed like his like
kind of getting a little bit close
rubbing up against us that under main
other than John like you said have you
ever tried to face wrong have I ever one
try to face wrong that was exciting for
me when he sees this live was how was he
gonna react to the whole he he did he
wrote you killed it in cap locks his mom
approved and he was like wow yeah
nothing effective I mean I don't mean
that like that but he he's so proud of
me and he he knew how uncomfortable I
was this week and doing all this I mean
I made a mask of his face and put it on
our tongue so like so what did they not
show you in order to free to help that I
she came with the mask and she's like
look up John it would look make me very
comfortable if you put this mask on and
we'll try the role of the face for the
John's face I've never seen that in
covering the show for you wow that's
footage is priceless I can't believe
they need to show I can't believe
it's hilarious but then it was weird
because I was like this it was like like
I don't know yeah listen I think she's
getting more comfortable getting closer
to people thinking I think whatever
you're doing it's working yeah okay good
you know we learned tonight that Nick
Lachey did not remember his first date
with Vanessa and I'm wondering what was
your first date big man
it was actually at Gibson's steakhouse
in Chicago we even have a painting of it
in our house yeah really see so you
can't forget that here no trouble
[Music]